we will be demanding from our Western
partners to accept the reality at the
United States and European Union go back
to the full implementation of their
obligations or the joint comprehensive
action plan and then iran as iran stated
many times restores the observation of
those obligations which it assumed
exclusively or on a voluntary basis and
probably it would be an ideal resolution
solution russia's Foreign Minister has
warned that the Iranian nuclear deal is
at risk due to what he called the
obvious methods of intimidation from the
US Sergei Lavrov is hosting his Iranian
counterpart for nuclear talks in Moscow
Mohammad Javad Zarif thanked Russia for
its support after the US withdrawal from
the Iran nuclear deal but accused Europe
of not doing enough to get past the
sanctions mosaic issued on the stance of
European countries regarding the nuclear
deal politically they have expressed
support but they haven't really taken
any practical steps to counter US
sanctions they haven't taken any steps
to implement their own commitments so
Iran and Russia agreed that the
Europeans should fulfill their
obligations under the nuclear deal well
our senior political analyst moment
Bashara joins us now from Doha Marwan we
saw there a great show of unity together
in that press conference but it does
seem to be the same lines that are
coming out again and again doesn't it
yes there certainly are a repetition
ever since the u.s. walked out of the
nuclear deal and basically walked off
Syria but be that as it may what's new
is not the content it's the style it's
the character there's so much confidence
in that press conference and there's so
much confidence in Iranian Russian role
in the Middle East nowadays that the
United States has basically walked away
from a lot of its previous commitments
in the region and the fact that this
press conference is taking place at the
same time while war games are going on
between Russia Iran and China and China
this is the big elephant in the room the
fact that this trilateral war games are
going on for four days in the in the
Gulf means that the characterization of
their relationship and of their strategy
common strategy I must stress in the
region of course excuse of our what will
of confidence and of optimism if you
will now whether this will in fact bode
well for a stability and peace in the
region of course as a whole other
question it certainly is but it is an
interesting dynamic that is emerging how
do you see this playing right is the
u.s. stepping away from the region
because events in Iraq over the last 24
hours
and Syria would suggest otherwise well
look at it this way the the united
states forces and their allies were
attacked by hezbollah associated with
iran so they responded two days later
clearly the commander-in-chief is
hanging out somewhere in Florida playing
golf and preoccupied with what he calls
crazy Pelosi meaning crazy House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi I think the Russians and
the Iranians and the Chinese understand
that the commander in chief is not
really in full command at this point in
time he's preoccupied with other things
domestic and otherwise and that while
the US forces are more than capable to
respond to any threat to them in the
place like Iraq but when the Iraq
government itself calls the American
response to Kataeb Hezbollah that are
associated with Iran and that the
undermine Iraqi sovereignty where is the
American position so basically the
Russians and and the Iranians probably
to some degree the Chinese feel that the
United States when it came to the attack
against Aramco for example several
months ago or the escalations in various
parts of the of the region whether it is
Libya which there was a question about
that they
no American role in Libya at this point
in time really to be to be to be
considered when it comes to Yemen again
more of the same and certainly when it
comes to Syria so all in all there's a
feeling that the United States is not
hat it's not full-on when it comes with
the Middle East and I think I hate to
use this metaphor but I'm really using
it just to explain you know when the
mice walk away it was funny when the
cats walk away the mice you know come to
the scene so in so many ways now the
United States is not is not it's not
there in full force and hence Russia and
Iran and to some degree and that's a big
story China are coming in and filling
filling in the vacuum and and just
quickly Marwan an interesting final
question at that press conference on
Libya this adds yet another confusing
and complicated dynamic to to a region
that funkier Keys complicated enough
what to be honest with you every single
press conference nowadays is like or
well you know come alive they use words
like peace and security when they're
doing war games they talk about peace
and ceasefire and when they talk about
Libya when in fact a lot of them are
really steep destabilizing forces in
Libya in Libya there is supposed to be a
three point plan that has to do with
ceasefire and all the stakeholders meet
in Germany and discuss it and then
somehow you know arrive at a direct
dialogue between the Libyans everyone
else everyone is be actually being a
stabilized destabilizing force while
claiming to be a stabilizing force okay
Marwan Bashara greens get your analysis
thank you very much